[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جواهر
استهدافه عمران خان يعيد باكستان لاسوء
ذكرياتها اغتيالات بدات مع الياقات علي
خان ولم تنتهي مع بنظير بوتو
ايمان يا رشود
خيار وروسيا للنووي لن يتعدى سلاحا
تكتيكيا لكن متى يقلق الغرب حين تغير
القذفات والغواصاتها
نظام ايران مجبر على التغيير حتى لو نجى
من السقوط وشرطه الاخلاق سيئه السمعه قد
تكون اول ضحيه
وتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
اقالات العراق الامنيه بين تطهير المؤسسات
وتصفيه الحسابات والسوداني مطالب بابرانيه
[موسيقى]
اذا العنف السياسي يعود ليطل براسه في
باكستان بعدما تعرض عمران خان فعليا رئيس
الوزراء السابق لمحاوله اغتيال خان اصيب
برصاصه في قدمه خلال تجمع سياسي اليوم
بمدينه وزير اباد وهو في حاله مستقره
وفقما قال احد مساعديه بعد ما نقل الى
مستشفى فيلاغور بعد الهجوم ومساء اليوم
اتهمت حركه انصاف بزعامه عمران خان كل من
رئيس الوزراء ووزير الداخليه والاستخبارات
المحليه بمحاوله اغتياله ومنذ يوم الجمعه
الماضي كان خان يتقدم مسيره بالسيارات
والحافلات من مدينه لاهور نحو العاصمه
اسلام اباد في ايطاليا حمله للمطالبه
بانتخابات جديده بعد ما اقصى من منصبه في
ربي هذا العمل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فؤاد شودري المتحدث باسم حركه انصاف
بزعامه خان قال لرويترز انها كانت محاوله
اغتيال واضحه مضيفا ان عمران خان اصيب
وانه لو لم يوقف الناس مطلق النار في مكان
الحادث لقد على قيادات حزب حركه انصاف
وقتل رجل يشتبه في انه هاجم خانه حسب ما
افادت وسائل الاعلام محليه دون تحديدا
كيفيه مقتله في حين اعتقلت الشرطه رجل اخر
[موسيقى]
كاريكا
سبق الحادث فوز رئيس الحكومه السابق عمران
خان في انتخابات تشريعيه نهايه الاسبوع
الماضي حسب ما اعلنت مفوضيه الانتخابات
الباكستانيه ومنذ الاطاحه به من منصبه في
ابريل من
ربيع العام الماضي بناء على اقتراح بحجم
الثقه يطالب بطل الكراكت السابق باجراء
الانتخابات على الفور الا ان الحكومه تفضل
الانتظار حتى اكتوبر من العام المقبل
للعمل على اعاده ضبط الاوضاع الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
في ايطالي ردود الفعل المحليه وصف رئيس
الباكستانيه عارف علي في تغريده على تويتر
اطلاق النار بانه محاوله اغتيال شنيعه
واعرض عن ارتياحه انا اصابه خان غير حرشه
بدوره قال رئيس الوزراء الحالي شهب شريف
انه يدين اطلاق النار على عمران خان مضيفا
انه طلب تقرير عن الحادث وشدد على انه لا
ينبغي ان يكون للعنف مكان في سياسه
باكستان
بالحديث عن العنف السياسي كانت مدينه
واحده عاملا كانت هذه المدينه فعليا هي
عامل مشترك بين جميع الاحداث ففي عام
اغتيل لياقه علي خان اول رئيس وزراء
لباكستان في مدينه البندي وفي عام 1979
اطاح انقلاب عسكري برئيس الوزراء بالفقار
علي بوتو واعدمه شنقا في المدينه نفسها
مجددا في عام 2007 اغتيلت رئيسه الوزراء
بنازير بوتو في هجوم بالاسلحه والقنابل
بعد اقامه تجمع انتخابي واصيبت في العنق
والصدر بعدها فجرا انتحاري نفسه لتلقى
مسرحها
وينضم الينا من اسلام اباد السفير جويد
حفيظ سفير باكستان لدى السعوديه سابقا
اهلا بك سعاده السفير فعليا يعني ربما
السؤال البديهي من صاحب
المصلحه في محاوله اغتيال
رئيس الوزراء السابق وما الدوافع السياسيه
من وراء ذلك
طبعا
من الذي يستفيد من هذه المعاونه اغتيال
المؤسفه
الاستخبارات الخارجيه لها ضلع في هذه
الجريمه
وليست هذه جريمه
محليه كما يزن عمران خالد
[تصفيق]
انا هناك يعني تداعيات عديده
للقدر اين هناك اتظاهرات في جميل مدن
اليوم
فالعدوا يريد الفوضى
وانزلاق الامن في في باكستان
حزب عمران خان يتهم رئيس الوزراء ووزير
الداخليه والاستخبارات وهياتهامات خطيره
جدا
وهو
همم
شعبي الاتهام الى رئيس الوزراء
وزير الداخليه
ورئيس الاستخبارات ولكن كمان نقول كل متهم
بريء حتى يتم
قد يكون قد يكون نظيف
لانه
كبيره بين المعارضه وبين الحكومه وهذا شيء
موصف جدا ولا عوده مشهوره
بالتوتر
اين كان الامن فعليا خاصه بانه هناك حديث
بانه اذا لم يتدخل بعد العناصر من الجمهور
لحمايه خان كان يمكن ان يكون هناك يعني
يتعرض لاصابه بالغه اكثر
شهيد هناك
ربما
اذا اذا اغتيل كانت هذه الكارثه كبيره
للايميل للبلاد انه هو الان
يخوضوا اكبر هز شعبيه
بعد بعد
[تصفيق]
الانتخابات التي جرت في همم
شعر الرادي وهو فرس حزمه فاس في هذه
بعد هذه
محاوله الاغتيال
وهو سوف يزداد شعبيه في البلاد ولكن ما هو
موصفه وجوه التي بين الحكومه والمعارضه
ازدادت بعد هذه
الحادثه
سفير باكستان لدى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه السابقه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
شهاده براءه جديده نالتها اوكرانيا في ما
يتعلق بالاتهامات الروسيه لها بالتجهيز
لاستخدام قنبله قذره المدير العام لوكاله
الطاقه رافاييل جروسي قال ان المفتشين لم
يرصده اي انشطه او مواد نوويه لم يعلن
عنها بعد اكتمال التفتيش
لثلاثه لمواقع في اوكرانيا
عمليات التفتيش الميداني تمت في المواقع
الثلاثه بناءا على طلب الحكومه الاوكرانيه
على الفور رحب وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيبا باعلان الوكاله وشكارها على
ما وصفه بالتعاون الممتاز والسريع في
مواجهه الاكاذيب الروسيه وكان مجلس الامن
القومي الروسي جدد اتهام اوكرانيا بالتجه
لقنبله قذره بمشاركه دول الغربيه وقال
سكريت المجلس نيكولاي بتروشيف ان الغرب
يريد محو العرقيه الروسيه في شرق اوكرانيا
لكن في مقابل تبرات اوكرانيا من تهمه
القنبله القذره فان الحديث لا ينقطع عن
تخطيط روسيا لاستخدام النووي تقارير عن ان
جنرالات بوتر ناقشوا الخيارات بدقه بينما
يعيش الغرب يعيش حاله من الترقب والقلق
فلقدره على الكشف المبكر عن ضرب نوويه من
الصعوبه بمكان كون السلاح النووي التكتيكي
يمكن ان يحمل على وسائل متنوعه صحيفه
نيورك تايمز الامريكيه نقلت عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ان الجنرالات الروس ناقشوا كيف
ومتى يمكنهم استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه في اوكرانيا الصحيفه افادت بان
اداره الرئيس الامريكي اذا كانت في حاله
من القلق الشديده بعد ما علمت بتلك
المناقشات منت اكتوبر الماضي المسؤولون
الامريكيون تحدثوا اكثر من مره عن عدم
رؤيتهم لاي دليل على اعداد مثل هذه
الاسلحه وانه لم يتم رصد اي مركبات قادره
على اطلاق صواريخ مثل ار اس 24 يارس وهي
تتحرك الى مواقع الاطلاق
اسهمت سلسله من المكالمات بين وزير الدفاع
الروسي سرقه ونظرائه الغربيين ايضا في
تخفيف التوترات لكن رغم ذلك استمر لكراملا
بالتلويح بعصا النووي بتزامني مع معانات
قوته من الانتكاسات في ساحه المعركه على
ارض الجاره الغربيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المسؤولون الامريكيون قالوا لنيورك تايمز
ان الرئيس الروسيبلاديمير بوتن لم يشارك
في المناقشات حول الاسلحه النوويه امر
يقلل من اهميه المناقشات فاي كان ما ناقشه
الجنرالات فان القرار بشان تجاوز العتبه
النوويه ام لا سيتخذه بوت وحده والرجل لم
يظهر اي مؤشر حتى الان على استعداده لقبول
رد الفعل العنيف الكارثي الذي سيتلقاه ردا
على اي استخدام للاسلحه النوويه
تصنف الاسلحه النوويه عموما بانها اما
استراتيجيه او تكتيكيه يتم نشر الاولى
لكسب الحرب والاخيره لكسب معركه فرديه
وفقا لمركز الابحاث الامنيه البريطاني فان
الترسانه التكتيكيه الروسيه محدوده في
نطاق مدى يصل الى حوالي 483 كلمترا مقارنه
بمدى اربعه الاف و830
مثلا لصاروخ نووي استراتيجي الخطوره في
التكتيكيه تكمن بانه يمكن استخدام روسيا
لها بوسائل عده اولها من غواصه من فئه
اوسكار العامله في البحر الاسود او عبر
الطائرات المقاتله سو 27 التي تنشرها
روسيا على اراضي حلفتها بيلاروسيا كما
يمكن ان تطلق باستخدام قاذفات صواريخ
اسكندر ام ارض ارض وكذلك المتفاعلات الدفع
السفن الذي يستطيع اطلاق وظائف مدفعيه
نووي يمكن لروسيا ان تختار اطلاق صاروخ
نووي على اوكرانيا اما كتحذير او للتاثير
في ساحه المعركه وفق خبراء عسكريه قد
تختار روسيا استخدامها سلاح منخفض القوه
في منطقه غير ماهوله بالسكان في البلاد
يبلغ نصف قطر الانفجار لاصغر الاسلحه
التكتيكيه حوالي 500 متر لذلك من المحتمل
ان يتم ذلك دون خسائر في الارواح ومن
محتمل ان تضطر روسيا الى اطلاق عدد من
الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه بما يكفي ربما
لنشر الاشعاع عبر جزء من خط المواجهه
بالتالي نزع السلاح فيه حتى مع ذلك فان
ميزه السيطره على ساحه المعركه لاي انفجار
من هذا القبيل سيطغى عليها رد الفعل
السياسي الدولي ضد موسكو وستفاقم هذا
الامر اذا اعتبرت الصين كما هو متوقع مثل
هذه الخطوه استفزازا خطيرا جدا وبالتالي
قد تخاطر موسكو بخساره ابرز واقوى حلفاءها
المعدودين بالاساس هذا السؤال وغيره
سنطرحه على ضيفنا من باريس الدكتور محمد
سيف الدين الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه
والشان الروسي سيد او دكتور محمد يعني
اطرح عليك السؤال الاخير الذي همم يعني
قلت منذ قليل هل يمكن همم من خلال قراءتك
لشخصيه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوت
والقرارات التي اتخذها بالسابق
والاستراتيجيه الحربيه التي وضعها هل يمكن
ان يخسر الصين والهند وحلفاء وان تصبح
روسيا منبوذه اذا لجا الى النووي
مساء الخير بدايه اعتقد ان الامر يعني
بخصوص استخدام الاسلحه النوويه غير مرتبط
فقط بشخصيه الرئيس الروسي هو مرتبط
باستراتيجيه الروسيه بشكل اساس وهو يمر
مرتبط بالمرحله التي وصلت اليها المواجهه
بين روسيا وبين الغرب من ناحيه اخرى اعتقد
ان بحث استخدام الاسلحه النوويه همم لا
يقتصر على روسيا الان هو يعني هذا الموضوع
هو مطار بحث في معظم مراكز التفكير
الاستراتيجي وفي همم يعني في اروي قد صنع
القرار الغربيه والشرقيه بما فيها روسيا
وما فيها يعني عواصم عواصم اخرى لان
السلاح النووي يعني في المحصله هو سلاح
ردع وليس سلاح استخدام بشكل يعني همم متاح
في معظم الاوقات عندما تصل الامور في
اوكرانيا الى الى مرحله مرحله نهايه
المطاف وبالتالي حسم النتائج خساره روسيا
بشكل كامل او خساره الغرب اعتقد ان هذا
يكون النقطه او هذه تكون النقطه الاكثر
ترجيحا لاستخدام مثل هذه الاسلحه اشرتم في
المقدمه الى مجموعه من النقاط المهمه جدا
ومنها خساره الحلفاء لن تخاطر موسكو بشكل
سهل بخساره الراي العام الدولي وهناك
معركه كبيره جدا على الراي العام وقد
اشرتم الى اجزاء او الى نواعم مهمه جدا
منها بخصوص استخدام القنبل القذره او
بخصوص استخدام الاسلحه النوويه التكيه
اعتقد عند هذا المستوى من المواجهه الان
في هذه اللحظه ليس هناك ما يبرر استخدام
هذه الاسلحه ليس هناك من داعي حتى بالنسبه
لموسكو لاستخدام هذا النوع من الاسلحه عند
هذا المستوى من ال- من المواجهه لان
مجموعه من الوسائل المهمه جدا تتوفر لدى
موسكو ايضا لدى الطرف الاخر بالنسبه
لموسكو الان الوسيله المفضله هي استخدام
العصا الاقتصاديه او البعد الاقتصادي لان
الضغط يزداد في الغرب معدلات تضخم في اعلى
مستويات لها الان يتجاوزت منذ اسبوع حتى
الان عتبه 11% وصلت الى 11.6% من
والتضخم حرب الطاقه ال يعني ما يحدث في
الطاقه الخلافات الغربيه البينيه ايضا
هناك يعني معاناه في الاقتصاد الروسيات
معدلات البطاله
يعني هذا التطورات لا تتيح استخدام النووي
في هذه اللحظه
موضوع
القنبله القذره همم وبالتالي يعني هم
حلفاء من نفس ال يعني هم حلفاء من همم
يمكن ان يعطي لروسيا او لا يعطيها الحق
بذلك يعني كيف للعالم ان يتاكد من انه
كانت اوكرانيا ستلجا للقنبله القذره ام لا
هي جزء من معركه الراي العام ومعركه
المعلومه في هذه اللحظه وهذا امر لا يمكن
حسمه جوابا على سؤالك لا يمكن يحاسمه بشكل
كامل دائما هناك هوامش للدول لتناول فيها
في هذه الموضوعات موضوع استخدام اسلحه لها
تاثير بعيد المدى من مثل القنبله القذره
او القنابل النوويه التكتيكيه هي مواضيع
تؤثر جدا في الشعوب وهي تثير وتنشر الخوف
وبالتالي هي مربحه لمن يطلقها اعلاميا
وهذا ما يحدث في هذه المعركه الطرفان
يتبادلان التهامات لا يمكن حسم هذه
الاتهامات الا بالنظر لما يحدث على الارض
وبدلائل وبتحقيقات طويله الامل يعني ما
كان يحدث في دول اخرى من استخدام عن اسلحه
محرمه دوليه او اسلحه غير تقليديه كانت
تجري حوله تحقيقات طويله المدى وتمتد عبر
سنوات وبالتالي اعتقد ان ما يراد من هذه
التصريحات هو استخدامها ويعني صرف نتائجها
في نتائج المعركه
وليس همم الفوز والخساره الميدانيه لانه
كما قلت سابقا الامر ليس متاح في هذه
اللحظه اللحظه نظرا للخيارات الاخرى
المتوفره والاقل كلفه شكرا جزيلا لك
الدكتور محمد سيف الدين الباحث في
العلاقات الدوليه والشان الروسيه
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا ولكن بعد الفاصل
الامير محمد بن سلمان يطلق من السعوديه
اول شركه لتصنيع السيارات الكهربائيه في
الشرق الاوسط
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد احتجاجات وايران تدخل
الاسبوع الجديده والغضب الشعبي في الشارع
ما زال مستمرا كما في الاسابيع الماضيه
اليوم شهدت شوارع مدينتي كرج واراك حضوره
كفيفا خلال مراسم ذكرى اربعينيه مقتل
الشابه حديث نجا في والشاب شهيد على يد
القوات الامنيه بعض المتظاهرين لقطات
فيديو لمواطنين متوجهين الى مقبره كرج
للمشاركه في مراسم اربعينيها في مواجهه
القوات الامنيه ردد الحاضرون شعارات ضد
النظام مثل هذا العام مدم وخامس
[تصفيق]
قوات الامن
احياء ذكرى الشابه حديثه واطلقت الغاز
المسير للدموع للتفريق المجتمعين بينما
قال محتجون ان السلطات الامنيه استهدفت
بالرصاص الحقيقه المشاركين في المراسم
[موسيقى]
ومع تواصل المظاهرات وجهها 40 محاميا
ايراليا في مجال حقوق الانسان انتقادات
علنيه للسلطات معربين عن اعتقادهم بان
النظام سيسقط خاصه وان القمع لم يعد يخيف
المحتاجين المحامون المنتشرون داخل وخارج
ايران قالوا في بيانه ان الحكومه غارقه في
وهم اسكات الاصوات بالقمع والاعتقال
والقتل الا ان طوفان الناس سيسقط الحكومه
في النهايه حسب ما جاء في البيان واعربت
منظمات حقوق انسان عن الخشيه من ان
يواجهها منهم داخل البلاد من هؤلاء
المحامين خطر الاعتقال بسبب البيان الذي
وقعوا عليه
[موسيقى]
رونالدو رونالدو
[تصفيق]
وفي مقال تحليليه لواشنطن بوست قال الكاتب
ديفيد اجوتس ان نصل القمع في ايران بدا
يتفكك وان مرشد ايران سيكون مرغما على
تقديم التنازلات لكن براي اجووس لن يكون
الاصلاح في قضيه الحجاب خيار سهلا لان
خامنئي واستنادا على تصريحاته يعتقد انه
بمجرد تقديم التنازلات ستبدا سلطه النظام
في التاكل لذا كثيرا ما يستشهد من اي
بانهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي خلال عهد
كورباتشوف بسبب التدخلات الغرب ومؤامرته
ويحاول اسقاط ما حدث حينها على الاحتجاجات
الايرانيه المتكرره لكن كل هذا لا يغلق
الباب امام فكره التغيير الاختياري قبل
الاضطرار للتغيير الاجباري وربما تكون
شرطه الاخلاق اول من يدفع الثمن ثمان
التغيير بسبب سمعتها السيئه هذا فضلا عن
ان النساء بدانا في تحديها بشكل واسع
واصرنا يسرنا في الشوارع من دوني حجاب
[موسيقى]
رئيس تحرير مجله مختارات ايراني اهلا بك
معنا سيد محمد يعني ان لم يسقط هذا النظام
ما هي حدود التنازلات التي يمكن ان يقدمها
واصلا هل فكره التنازلات وارده عنده يعني
يستشهد بسقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي ويقول بانه
سقوط بدا مع اول تنازل ايضا داخل الايراني
هناك حديث بانه سقوط الشاه بدا عندما قال
سمعت صوت الثوره
اهلا وسهلا بيكي انا اتفق معك في هذا لانه
النظام في ايران ربما يعتقد الان ان
التنازلات اشبه بكره ثلج لانه التقديم
تنازل معناه تقديم تنازل اخر وبالتالي اذا
اتجه النظام الى هذا الخيار فانه سيقوم
مضطر الى الاستمرار في هذا الخيار وتقديم
مزيد من التنازلات بالفعل النموذج
السوفيتي والنموذج الشاه وهي نماذج ماثله
امام النظام الايراني وبالتالي لا اتصور
انه في مجال او في وارد ان يقدم تنزلات
للمحتاجين بالعكس انا اتظاهر انه الان يرى
ان اللعبه الصفريه وانه اما ان ينتصر على
المحتاجين او لا شيء في النهايه همم
بالتالي انا تظهر انه اتباع مزيد من القمع
همم على مستوى الشارع في المرحله القادمه
سيدعي النظام امام اختبار صعب لانه
استمرار الاحتجاجات بهذا الشكل ده يجعلها
تستقدم مزيد
المحتجين في الشارع وبالتالي همم تفرض
مزيد من الضغوط على النظام وتدعو امام
اختبار صعب خلال المرحله القادمه
امام هذا النظام الذي تتحدث عنه سيد محمد
يعني هل سيكون هناك كبش فداء يقدم نتحدث
هنا ربما عن شرطه الاخلاق تقدم للمعارضه
الايرانيه للناس التي تحتاج لتهدئ من
غضبها
انا اقصد بالاختبار الصعب هو اختبار
البقاء في الحكم
ربما النظام فوجئها باستمرار هذه
الاحتجاجات لو لاحظنا مثلا
بالمقارنه باحتجاجات 2009 و2/2017 او2019
ربما لم تستمر اسبوع او 10 ايام 10 ايام
على الاكثر الان نحن نتحدث عن اقتراب
الاحتجاجات من شهر من اتمام شهرها الثاني
وهذا ربما فاجا النظام بشكل كبير ااستمرار
الاحتجاجات معناها شيئين اول شيء هو مزيد
من انهاك قوات الامن والله لاحظنا همم ما
يتعلق به الحادث الذي وقع في شيراز وقبله
الحريق اللافت في همم سجن ايفين هذا معناه
انه هناك مشكله امام قوات الامن وامام
السلطات الامنيه في ايران في التعامل مع
ما يحدث في الشارع همم الشيء الاخر وانه
استمرار
الاحتجاجات معناها نجاحها في استقطاب مزيد
من الفئات مزيد من الاجيال في ايران همم
مزي المحتجين همم همم طبقات مختلفه
وبالتالي مزيد من الضغط على النظام في
المرحله القادمه لا اتصور ان النظام
يستطيع ان يقدم كشف فداء ولو لاحظنا الى
الان لم يتعرض
المتهمون به او المسؤولون عن
وفاه مهس اميني الى اي اجراء عقاب وهذا
معناه النظام ما زال مصر على تبني رؤيته
الخاصه على ان ما حدث هو شيء طبيعه وشيء
يتعلق بمرض المماس امين وانه لم يكن هناك
اعتداء عليها وانه ما يحدث في على الارض
هو مخطط خارجي تدعمه اطراف في الداخل انا
اتصور ان النظام سيتمنى او سيواصل تبني
هذه الروايه وبالتالي لن يقدم اي تنازلات
الى المحتاجين في الايام القادمه
سيد محمد يعني ما العامل الذي برايك كسر
جدار الخوف عند الايرانيين يعني نلاحظ مع
كل يعني مراسم تابين اليوم وقبل ذلك
باربعينيه مساء اماني كل تابين هو شراره
لتجديد هذه الاحتجاجات
هذا صحيح لانه بالفعل كل يوم في ايران
هناك اربعينيه جديده لم تعد هناك ساميني
واحده وانما اكثر من مهسه اميني عدد
القتلى يتزايد ومع ذلك الشارع ما زال
منتفضا هذا معناه انه حجز الخوف كسر
بالفعل كما كما قلت وان
المحتاجين يتزايدون في ال- ال- الشارع
لابد ان نشير لشيء مهم وانه المساله تتعلق
بتاثير المراه في الشارع الايراني الان
نحن نتحدث عن عدد خريجات الجامعات في
ايران اكثر من 50% عدد موظفات عدد كبير
اكثر من 50% اكتر ايضا وبالتالي هناك
تاثير كبير لما حدث لمسه امينه ولما حدث
لزملائها وزم- زميلاتها في الايام الماضيه
انا اتصور انه الجيل زد في ايران نحن
نتحدث عن عدد من يقل اعمارهم عن 24 عام في
ايران نحو 37% هذا معناه تاثير واسع وضغط
واسع على نظام
وانتفاضه مستمره للشارع الايراني على نحو
انا لا اعتقد ان النظام سيتحمله على المدى
الطويل والمدى المتوسط شكرا جزيلا لك من
القاهره محمد عباس ناجي رئيس تحرير مجلات
مخترعات ايرانيه على اراك
قلق المبعوث الامريكي الخاص بايران روبرت
مالي للعربيه ان السياسه المتحده اتجاهها
ايران لم تتغير سوف تعتمد الدبلوماسيه
للتعامل مع الملف النووي الايراني كما
اشار انه في حال فشل الدبلوماسيه ستلجا
للولايات المتحده الى الخيار العسكري
[موسيقى]
كليبلوماسيه هي افضل طريقه لتحقيق ذلك
سواء كانت خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه او
صفقه اخرى مازلنا نعتقد ان الدبلوماسيه هي
افضل طريقه للتعامل مع ذلك واذا فشلت
دبلوماسيه وفشل الضغط فقد اوضح الرئيس انه
يحتفظ بالحق في اللجوء كماذن اخير الى
الخيار العسكري لكن في الوقت الحالي لا
ينصب تركيزنا على التواصل الى الدفاع لان
عناصر ايران الاوليه كانت غير متوافقه مع
صفقه شهرين الماضيين لقد اتيحت لهم العديد
من الفرص لعقد صفقه حيث كان بامكانهم
تخفيف العقوبات التي يقولون انهم يريدونها
وقد ابتعدوا عن فرصه تلو الاخرى لكن في
اللحظه الاخيره اثار قضايا خارجيه لذلك
يركز على مفاوضات نوويه لا تسير في اي
مكان ولن تذهب الى اي مكان رشاد ان سبورت
[موسيقى]
على الفساد ام مذبح امنيه ام تصفيه حسابات
يقودها رئيس الوزراء العراقي الجديد محمد
شع- السوداني الذي يظهر او يظهر فعليا عكس
ما يبطن بحسب ما يتهممه منتقده فقبل
انتهاء تحقيقات سرقه القرن اعلنت الحكومه
العراقيه تفكيك اكبر شبكه لتهريب النفط في
البصره جنوب القلب جهاز الامن الوطني كشف
ان شبكه التهريب التي يقودها احد التجار
ضمت ضباطا بروطه بين عاليه وموظفينا كبار
اعتقلوا بموجب مذكرات قبض صادره عن القضاء
لكن كيف يتم التهريب الامن الوطني ذكر ان
شبكه التهريب تقوم باحداث ثقوب في خطوط
تصدير النفط الخام بحق الزبير النفطي
بالارقام كانت الشبكه تهرب بحدود بين خمسه
الى سبعه صها بسعه بسعه 50.000 لتر يوميا
اي حوالي 75 مليون شهريا بالعوده الى قضيه
سرقه القرن يجري القضاء العراقي تحقيقات
مع متهمين بسرقه ما يقدر بنحو 2.5 مليار
دولار من اموالي هيئه الضرائب العامه كما
اعلن سابقا هذا المبلغ الضخم جرى سحبه بين
سبتمبر من عام 2021 اغسطس من عام 2022 من
مصرف الرافدين الحكومي عبر 247 صكا ماليا
وحرر الى خمس شركه قامت بصرفها نقدا
مباشره لكن اثاره قضيه سرقه القرن
بالتزامن مع انطلاقه عمل حكومه السوداني
لم تكن بريئه من حيث توقيتها بحسب معارضين
لا بل ان هناك مخالف جديه من ان تتحول
معركه الفساد الى معركه تصفيات حسابات
ويدلل المعارضون على عليك بالمذبح الامنيه
التي حصلت امس لكن لماذا يشكك هؤلاء في
خطوات السودان البعض ما يزال ينظر الى
السوداني على الشكل الذي اشتهر به ضمن
المالك والمقصود طبعا رئيس الوزراء
العراقي الاسبق ورئيس ائتلاف دوله القانون
نور المالكي ويدفعون بان الحمل التي يشنها
السوداني على اجهزه الامن والاستخبارات
تتخذ من الحرب على الفساد ذريعه لتمرير
الاقالات الامنيه ويؤمنون بانها تاتي
استجابه لضغوط المالكي وزعيم ميليشيا
العصائر قيس الخزعلي لكن من هم المقالون
نتعرف عليهم
[موسيقى]
اعلنا ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان عن اطلاق شركه سير لصناعه السيارات
الكهربائيه اول علامه تجاريه سعوديه
لصناعه السيارات الكهربائيه في المملكه
وقال الامير محمد بن سلمان ان اطلاقا شركه
سير يهدفوا لدعم تطوير المنظومه الصناعيه
الوطنيه وجذب الاستثمارات المحليه
والدوليه واستحداث العديد من فرص العمل
للكفاءه المحليه بما يسهم في زياده الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي للمملكه خلال العقد
المقبل ودفعي عجله النمو الاقتصاديه ماشيا
مع رؤيه 20 30 ومن المتوقع ان تجذب
استثمارات اجنبيه مباشره بقيمه 562 مليون
ريال لدعم الاقتصاد الوطني وانتصل
مساهمتها في الناتج المحاليل الاجمالي
بشكل مباشر الى 30 مليار مع توفيرها
لثلاثين الف وظيفه بشكل شيرين وغير مباشر
بحلول عام 2034 وتعد شركه سير مشروعا
مشتركا بين صندوق الاستثمارات العامه
وشركه فوكس كون حيث ستحصل سير على تراخيص
تقنيه المكونات المتعلقه بالسيارات
الكهربائيه من شركه بي ام دبليو
لاستخدامها في تطوير المركبات
ومن الارض الى الجو حيث اعلنت اليوم عن
دخولها باستثمار قيمته 175 مليون دولار في
شركه فوليكوبتر لصناعه الطائرات العموديه
الكهربائيه ضمن مساعدها للاستحواذ على حصه
كبيره من الشركه واستعمل الشركه على تقديم
خدمات التاكسي الجويه الكهربائيه في نيوم
لتسهيل الربط بين مناطقها المختلفه بما
فيها هذه اللاين
واكساجون وتروجينه وتستهدف نيوم انشاء اول
منظومه تنقل مستدامه عامه ومتكامله على
مستوى العالم
وتستكون فكره التنقل الجو عبر سيارات
الاجره تتحول الى حقيقه يوميا لسكان يوم
وزوارها وستبني كل من نيوم وفلوكبتر
بالتعاون مع هيئه التيار المدني السعودي
منصه اختبار لدمجه نظام طائرات الاقلاع
والهبوط العموديه الكهربائيه مع منظومه
قطع التنقل المستقبل
[موسيقى]
وصل البابا فرنسيس اليوم الى البحرين في
زياره تستمر اربعه ايام هي الاولى له الى
المنامه
خلال زيارته التي تستمر حتى الاحد القاء
سبعه خطابات كما سيشارك بشكل خاص في ملتقى
البحرين للحوار الشرق والغرب من اجل
التعايش الانساني الذي افتتح اعمله صباح
اليوم
ضربه في واحد من اهم محاصلها الاحمرار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال ثلاثه من مستشار
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب انه
يفكر في اطلاق حملته الرئاسيه هذا الشهر
في حملته
الانتخابيه رئاسيه عقب الانتخابات النصفيه
للكونغرس والاستفاده من التقدم المتوقع
للاعضاء الجمهوريين واشاره رويترز الى ان
ترامب بدا يبحث عن موظفين للانضمام الى
حملته
[موسيقى]
خلافات الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب مع مسؤولين جمهوريين تكتمل حلقاتها
في كولورادو غير ان هذا الخلاف مع المرشح
لعضويه مجلس الشيوخ
الاخير في سحب المقعد
احدى ساحات معارك ترامب في كواليس الحزب
الجمهوري تشمل كولورادو فهناك دخل بحرب
كلميه اخرى مع المرشح عن الحزب لعضويه
مجلس الشيوخ جو عدي الاخير ارتكب غلطه قد
يمررها سياسيون اخرون لكنه وخزت ترامب حين
اكد عدم دعمه بالانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله ان قرر الرئيس السابق الترشح لا
بل اعلن ادعي على نيته تسير حمله الناشطه
لدعم اي منافس لترامب من الجمهوريين عام
2424 امثله بسكوت من سوس كارولينا
والسفينه في عهد ترامب نيكها اليه ومن ضمن
عثرات السنه الجمهوري ايضا وصف مبارزه
ثانيه بين بيضا وترامب على الرئاسه
بالممزقه للبلاد كما شدد على وجوب فعل
ترامب المزيد لمنع هجوم السادس من يناير
على مبنى الكونجرس
عروس
فعلى موقعه الخاص تروس صخره ترامب منه
واصفا اياه بالرانو اي الجمهوريه على
الورق فقط وهي عباره مهمه يستخدمها
المحافظون لوصف اعضاء الحزب الاكثر
اعتدالنا مضيفا ان ماجا لا تصوت للاغبياء
ذوي الاحواه الكبيره وفقه تعبيره وذلك في
اشاره للحركه التي تحمل اسم فلنجعل امريكا
مره اخرى عنواننا حملته الانتخابيه عام
[موسيقى]
حلقات الاخضر
سياسيه مؤكدا اعطاء الحقل ترامب لابداء
رايه ونيل حق نفسه
الحالي
ودعم المستقلين والمعتدلين في جميع انحاء
كلورادو لتسجيل النقاط على حساب البنات
واي تقع احسن منها ينهي اماله بتحقيق
المعادله الرابحه
[موسيقى]
تسعه شركات سبيس اكس المملوكه للملياردير
الامريكي الى الماس الى تلاقي 42000 قمر
[موسيقى]
صاروخ سبيس اكس هذا يحمل 60 قمرا صناعيا
لمدارها في الفضاء وخلال الاعوام المقبله
يامل الى الماسك ان يوفر خدمه الانترنت
للعالم عبر شركه ستارلينج من خلال 42000
قمر صناعي وهو رقم يزيد ب 15 ضعفا عن عدد
الاقمار الصناعيه التي تدور حاليا الارض
الغايه ايصال خدمه انترنت رخيصه وسريعه
للعالم وايضا ان يقتطع الى الماسك حصه من
ارباح قطاع الاتصالات العالمي ما سيسمح
لشركته بربح ما يتراوح بين 30 و50 مليار
دولار سنويا حاله تطبيق الخطه
اقمار ماسك الصناعيه لخدمه الانترنت تتميز
بان مدارها حول الارض اقرب من مثيلاتها
التابعه للدول او الشركات الاخرى ماذا
يقلل من انقطاع او تاخر الانترنت لدى
المستقبلين ايضا سترتبط اقمار ستار لينك
مع بعضها بشعاع الليزر ما يجعلك قادرا على
استخدام الانترنت بشكل مستمر وانت غير
القمر الذي يكون وقتها فوق منزلك لكن
الامر لا يخلو من جوانب سلبيه فازدحام
المدارس بالاقمار الصناعيه قد يزيد من
صعوبه رؤيه الاجسام او الكويتبات التي قد
تصطدم بالارض اضافه لذلك قد تعيق الاقمار
الصناعيه البحث عن كواكب عقوب سوداء جديده
اما الامر الاخطر فهو تلبد مدار الارض
بالشظايا في حال ارتطام الاقمار الصناعيه
ببعضها البعض او تصادم الشظايا المتطايره
ببعضها لكن خبراء يقولون ان الاخطار
المحرقه بمدار الارض لن تذبح رغبه الدول
او الشركه الحكومه ملزمه بممارسه مهام
حكومه تصريف الاعمال وليس مهام حكومه
مستقيله كان هذا التصريح او التكليف من
البرلمان اللبناني لحكومه نجيب ميقاتي
لانهاء اللقب حول رساله الرئيس المنتهيه
ولايته الكارثه التي وجهها ميشالون للمجلس
قبل انتهاء ولايته بيومه والتي اعتمر فيها
الحكومه مستقيله لم يهزم اذا ميقاتي في
مواجهته مع عون لكنه كذلك لم ينتصر ففي نص
تكليف في البرلمان ما يمنع الحكومه من
الاجتماع الا في الحالات الاستثنائيه
اما سوره اليوم فمن جنين الفلسطينيه تقتحم
الاليات الاحياء يقتلع الجنود الابواب
يسقط الرصاص مزيدا من الشباب لكن في جنين
ايضا تقام الاعراس يحتفل الشباب وينشر
الفرح وضاءه الانوار حتى لو كان الظلام
محيطه
اما فيديو اليوم فهو من باكستان وبعيدا عن
الرصاص الذي اخطا هدفه في محاوله اغتيال
عمران خان لكن هناك رصاصه ستان اصابتا
الهدف
رصاصه مناخ في الحقيقه عانت المحاصيل بشده
من الحر ثم جاءت الفياضانات العاربه لتقضي
على مانجا منها كان اكثر المحاصيل تضررا
هو الفلفل الحار الذي تحتل الباكستان
المرتبه الرابعه في انتاجه عالميه ضحى
المزارعون في جنوب باكستان بباقي محاصيل
لهم وجه المياه الفيضانات نحو حقول القطن
وغيرها لكن حتى بعد التضحيه لم ينجو سوى
ربع محصول الفلفل الحار